we resurrect the most lethal predators
this planet has ever seen come on not ya
kid we've taken things way too far
genetic power has now been unleashed
not on an island anymore this has to end
we've entered a new era welcome to
Jurassic world ready pg-13 how many can
you save 11 species blue is the last of
her kind
you'll never capture her we thought you
might know someone who could help a
rescue our what could go wrong hey blue
you know me come with me you know you
can't stay here it was all alive
the man who proved Raptors can follow
orders you've never thought how many
millions a trained predator might be was
their cell not blue they need it for
something else this is the most
dangerous creature that ever walked the
earth I said we shut this whole thing
down
hey girl you think what I'm thinking
genetic power has now been unleashed you
can't put it back in the box
if I won't make him back
remember you're the one who made me come
here I'll be all right
these creatures were here before us and
if we're not careful they're gonna be
Hereafter welcome to Jurassic world
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]